continúan las versiones encontradas
sobre lo que sucedió el martes en la
madrugada en Ucrania cuando la capital
kiev fue atacada con mayor intensidad
que noches anteriores esta era la noche
octava desde comenzó el mes de mayo en
que la ciudad era atacada con misiles
pero ese día se sintieron las defensas
aéreas trabajar con muchísima más
intensidad y con mucha más rapidez que
en otras ocasiones luego el gran general
de las fuerzas militares ucranianas el
general Valery habló de 18 misiles con
los que fueron atacados durante esa
madrugada a bloque seis de esos misiles
eran hipersónicos quinchal el arma tal
vez más potente que tenga Rusia en su
Arsenal y él decía que todos estos
misiles sumado a otros nueve drones
habían sido interceptados durante la
noche pero luego le respondió el
ministro de defensa ruso que dijo que
este número de quinchales no habían sido
a bloque Ucrania estaba exagerando que
habla que calculaban tres veces más y
luego también otras versiones desde
Rusia aseguraban que con uno de esos
misiles habían destruido una de las
baterías antiaéreas Patriotas que son
una de esas baterías de defensa
antiaérea más potentes que hay en el
mundo y que fueron dadas a Ucrania hace
pocas semanas por sus aliados
occidentales especialmente Estados
Unidos luego desde la defensa aérea
ucraniana dijo que no iban a comentar
sobre este asunto de los patrios y luego
dijeron que no estaba destruida y que
ninguno de esos misiles lograba destruir
esos tipos de batería antiaérea sin
embargo algunas cadenas norteamericanas
especialmente las CN de la CNN habló con
dos oficiales estadounidenses que
confirmaban que posiblemente estas
Patriots habían quedado dañadas Pero no
destruidas que estaban evaluando si era
necesario hacer reparaciones O cambiar
algunos de sus partes y si se podía
hacer dentro del país pero también
aseguraban que seguían operando en la
defensa no solamente de Ucrania sino
especialmente de kiev donde la población
sí tiene seguridad de que la madrugada
del martes fue una de esas noches más
difíciles que ha vivido desde el
comienzo de la invasión desde el año
pasado